[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand
I am from Whole Earth Catalog and it's
sort of suffuses the building tonight
I'm also from the long now foundation
another bit of orientation and it's
right over that way is the long now bar
called the interval right next to greens
they'll be open till 12:30 tonight just
in case you know how to keep partying
after the after party because they're
going to kick us out of this pier which
is run by Santa Fe Art Institute or
Center
San Francisco Art Institute and then
carry on and the wee hours if you want
you this whole event was organized by
people I wanted to introduce Ryan Phelan
and Danica Remmy
Brian's the dannika plans the courier
Danica's development and maker happened
of things and you guys can probably
explain a little bit of the house rules
tonight you need a mic yeah we're biked
sir Thank You Stuart oh and welcome
everyone to this evening's program when
we conceptualize what to do to celebrate
the whole earth 50th we thought what
could be better than for in-depth
conversations now they're kind of
compressed into 25-minute segments but
we tried and we wanted to take four
really important themes from the Whole
Earth Catalog and you have that
information in your brochure today as
well as BIOS on the speakers so we're
gonna try to really run this as promptly
as we can with my co-host here um one
other thing I Stewart mentioned the
after party and just want to make sure
everyone is thinking about making plans
to come over at the end this evening
enjoying the rest of the alumni that
have been honestly partying all day next
door so Danica what else and then I'd
like to bring the volume down a little
bit and remind everybody that we have a
hundred and forty three issues of whole
earth coevolution quarterly and the
catalogues on display and it's quite
amazing to walk the line from 1968 all
the way to 2002 and we stopped
publishing and so I hope you'll enjoy
the art the covers and the conversations
about where you were when you read one
of those or what you were doing at the
year that those were published I
encourage all of you to a hashtag
haulers 50th and hashtag stay foolish
and stay hungry and take no flashes in
the theater please but when you get into
the after-party
we encourage photos all over the place
so please enjoy and hashtag sfa i our
host for this evening San Francisco Art
Institute who have graciously given us
the atrium next door so with that with
that see you guys in a few minutes I'll
be back at the end of the program I'm
just
one more second to introduce the first
perspective giver on things there's
always faux images of Earth you know
that's a photograph then and that
thing's just a fun ball but it's best to
hear from somebody who's seen it raw the
Apollo nine astronaut rusty Schweickart
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart Ryan and and Danica
this is the 50th anniversary of the
Whole Earth Catalog it also is the 50th
anniversary of human beings seeing that
whole earth with their own eyes in in
the blackness of space it's the 50th
anniversary especially for me of the
Apollo program and not only do we
celebrate the intersection of the Whole
Earth Catalog and the Apollo program
today but 50 years ago was the same the
intersection was there 50 years ago it
all started the Whole Earth Catalog was
Stuart and the whole earth with Stuart
stoned one day and writing this this
historic thing why haven't we seen you
know a photograph of the whole earth and
of course Stuart then went around
wearing a sandwich board and we all know
the story
I've always chuckled at that but Stuart
was not the first person who had the
idea Fred Hoyle made this wonderful
statement back in 1948 and I think this
is the essence of what we're really
talking about today human beings have
now had that view and the first people
who had it were I got to go back on
there first people who had that vision
were the Apollo 8 crew as they went out
around the moon in that Christmas time
in 1968 and this is what Bill Anders saw
when he looked out the window
the real blackness of space not with the
earth in the view or the Sun but just
the Stars and that made a huge
impression on him this is a slightly
different picture when he looked at it
at another time without the Sun and the
earth shine on the moon the moon
interfered with that and he really
understood
the blackness of space three orbits
later they went around the first three
orbits going backward around the moon
and it was pretty boring watching the
craters but they turned around on the
fourth orbit and this was what the the
sight they saw coming over the horizon
this was the first time human eyes had
seen this beautiful planet contrasted
against the the greys of the moon and
the blackness of space to me this was
the moment of cosmic birth the moment
when humans first left the womb of
Mother Earth and moved out into the
universe this is historically the moment
we're living it now that's a moment of
10,000 years perhaps for how long now or
perhaps a few dozen years but this was
this is the important element we are
born out of the womb of Mother Earth it
is only as human life is born out of the
womb that it begins to occur she ate
love and begin to take care of its
mother and we as we move out into the
cosmos must both love and look back at
and take responsibility for the mother
from which we emerged you'll hear that
theme again and again so this is our
responsibility and we must accept this
responsibility as we move out into space
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You rusty I'd like to invite
Stephanie Mills to the stage I'm so
sorry Kevin Kelly excuse me
no panic Stephanie Kevin Kelly and I
just want to say Kevin Kelly came on the
scene in 1984 almost by mail order
Stewart was in a panic he was in the
thick of trying to do the whole ear
software catalog and he'd been
corresponding and exchanging columns
with Kevin and Kevin came to our rescue
and the rest is history
thank you so much so I want to talk
about the other part of what you see on
the cover of the Whole Earth Catalog
what you see of course at first is the
whole earth and that cosmic overview
that Russy just talked about like almost
transcendent --nt view that you get of
our own life but beneath that on the
cover anyway is the second news and I
think the second revelation which is
access to tools which is I think almost
as important as the overview of the
whole earth access to tools connotates
that you're going to do something with
tools and what we normally do with tools
is make things and so what I want to
talk about is that connection between
the whole earth catalogue and the maker
movement that we see today and it was a
very direct line I believe what the
catalog was being used for and a lot of
people was not necessarily trying to
giving him a new perspective on the
environment or the planet but they
needed to know how to dig a well they
were going to go back to the land and
they needed to figure out how to build a
roof or they wanted to try to homeschool
their kids and they wanted some
suggestions about curriculum it was
about how to do stuff how to make things
how to make things happen and that
how to was what the Kellogg was selling
so to speak in the very beginning and it
made a huge difference I think many
people can testify the fact that the
whole worth caring her lives and they
change lives because it told them how to
do things that they didn't even know
that they wanted to do told them how to
do things they wanted to know how to do
but it most importantly opened up this
gate way to possibilities about things
that didn't even know that they wanted
to do and I think that enlargement of
the possibility space the tools bring is
one of the great nudges that the Whole
Earth Catalog made to our culture it
kind of opened up the possibility space
and so people like myself who
encountered it for the first time said
wait a minute you can actually you know
build your own house you can actually
buy dynamite and blow up a boulder you
can actually figure out how to have bees
in your backyard that's all possible I
didn't even think about that before and
now I have that possibility because I
know that these tools exist I know that
this information exists and so I think
that was this AHA that the culture had
where it was taking a long American
tradition of doing things on your own
making stuff in basements anybody who
grew up on a farm would realize that
there were makers the farmers are makers
by necessity but there's two things that
were different this time one was this
enlargement about the kinds of things
that you can learn how to do yourself it
wasn't just fixing farm machinery it was
learning how to pan for gold it was
learning how to program a programmable
calculator it was
it was learning how to knit in an
old-fashioned way they had died out all
these things were now something that you
could learn how to do not just the
things that your grandfather or
grandmother knew and secondly I think
it's sped up accelerated the rate of
learning and it accelerated it in a very
major way
where before if you wanted to find out
how to do something it was almost
impossible to connect with that correct
information libraries were very very
small book stores were pathetically
under stocked there was simply no way to
find out how to do these things we we
don't really even remember how bad it
was and so this acceleration has only
gained speeds and so now we have the
extension of the whole earth catalogue
which was the web and then we had an
extension of that web which is YouTube
and I think as we look at this movement
to take tools and to make things and to
expand our possibilities I think of no
better example of the way in which the
acceleration has happened other than the
millions of YouTube videos of people who
have taken what they know and they're
sharing it and telling other people how
to do what they have learned to do and
that acceleration is really really
underappreciated right now it's it's
massively important massively faster
than any way we could have imagined and
I think a lot of the stuff that we're
seeing worldwide in terms of people
making things starting things making
things happen has been because the
access to tools that the whole earth
initiated has accelerated and expanded
in the form of YouTube and has gone on
to really change what we think about as
culture and as an indication of the
importance of YouTube I want to
introduce the next speaker who is a
YouTube maker star Simone yurts is a
maker innovator creator inventor who has
a massive youtube following and she
began a channel about what she called
shitty robots she has a sense of humor
she's an entertainer as well and she'll
be up here to tell you about serve this
next phase of the maker movement
Simone
hello thank you so much Kevin
my name is Simone and yeah I'm a maker
and inventor I kind of go between the
two titles depending on what mood I'm in
I like inventor because it makes it
sound like I'm in a cartoon but I'm
definitely a maker and part of the maker
community but maybe more so in maker
entertainment and I run a YouTube
channel where I build different projects
mostly robotics or that's what I'm
mostly known for shitty robots and
whenever somebody doesn't hasn't seen
them and I say that I build shitty
robots they're like don't talk yourself
down and I'm like no but they're
supposed to be shitty that's the whole
point so here just to show you some
examples here's an alarm clock that I
made to help me wake up in the morning
this video on different platforms has
been seen around 80 million times which
probably makes me the person on all the
planet Earth that most people have seen
getting slapped in the face with a
rubber hand and I'm not sure what type
of legacy that is but I'll take it
here's a lipstick girl bot that I made
because makeup is hard
[Music]
and here's a robot that I made to help
me serve soup this one takes a little
while so it's probably gonna eat up the
rest of my time here for the intro but
let's wait for the punchline maybe I'm
more in the business of keeping a
straight face more than anything but
yeah without more further ado let's
bring Kevin Kelly back out
[Applause]
maybe we should progress the slide or
maybe we should just keep this it's it's
a pretty it's a good frame so our
purpose now is to kind of think about
the role of making in the world the role
of being able to allow people to make
new things and one of the other
attendees here tonight is Neil
Gershenfeld who runs a Fab Lab and one
of his points is that the seemingly
direction that we're going to is will
get to the point where the tools will be
so available and cheap that basically
it's some point in most people's lives
they will make something just like today
and most educated middle-class lives
people will write something you know
writing in the past a thousand years ago
we've been the almost impossible thing
for most people to do because they
weren't even literate and they had very
little occasion to have to write
anything now writing is a common thing
that everybody does and I think making
is headed in that same direction you
won't make most of the things in your
lives but you'll make something at some
point in your life and I wonder if you
have any kind of feelings about whether
you felt that you are a maker now
because the tools are easier or what why
are you making things and you know would
you have made them 10 years ago well 10
years ago I was teenager and not really
interested in robotics robotics um yeah
I mean I I think definitely I so badly
want the maker movement to be this kind
of antidote to consumerism and be an
alternative to or instead of buying
things you make things and instead of
throwing things away you fix things but
I've kind of been looking at the pattern
of how I'm making and I realize it's
mostly just me buying a bunch of
materials and tools and it's like it's
it's in some way it's easy for it to
become a little bit like a gear sport
and I like makers faces are a good
compromise and
where it's like oh we can give people
access to tools and access to making
without having to get all these six this
expensive gear but yeah I don't know of
course tools getting cheaper like
they're being raspberry PI's for $3 or
$5 that's I mean it's it's huge it's
such a game-changer you can take the
risk of making mistakes when you're not
gambling huge investments and did you
when you were growing up you said you
were teenager you weren't thinking about
robotics when did you have start
thinking about robotics we need to kind
of realize oh my gosh I even I could be
making robots it's it was honestly not
until I saw another woman give a lecture
on robotics and she was she was this
hardware hacker and I remember seeing it
cuz like I grew up with a really geeky
older brother who would pick computers
apart and who would program and stuff
like that but I was always like no
that's not for me and it wasn't until I
saw another woman that I could kind of
project myself onto that I was like wow
if she can do that then I can do that
too and it suddenly was like just this
like what are you saying
curtain fall down there was a aha moment
maybe that's through Simone grew up in
Sweden until very recently so I was yes
do you not say that oh god dammit I miss
up idioms all the time it's it's how
people catch me but I asked you I was
like you were like what do you want me
to say when I enter you and I was like
tell people I'm Swedish like no what is
this nice to know that I might mess
things up yeah
the curtain fell down from my from my
ignorant face and I saw the world of
making and I as a woman can do this too
[Applause]
so do you have any any sense of like do
you wish you had access to more tools do
you what would you need if you could
wave a magic wand to kind of make your
life richer in terms of making things is
it cheaper tools more tools more time
more information honestly at this point
it's just more time like that's
definitely the limiting factor and it
gets to this weird point when you're
like I mean I started my youtube channel
three years ago and I was just like
doing these parties they're fine and I
started putting them online and it's
like grows to this point when you kind
of start a company and you're like
running more of a business where it's
like I don't have time to make things
anymore and so I really wish that I had
more time that's the biggest so we
should make a machine that made more
time right that's actually I mean I feel
like a lot of people have tried to
attempt that but I'll give it a go but
I'm kind of interesting interested in
like when did the word maker come around
do you remember when people started
identifying themselves as makers cuz now
is definitely think would be like I'm a
maker I actually think it was a
marketing term devised by Dale Daughtery
who worked for Tim O'Reilly and wanted
to do a magazine that was about like
cool tools about how to make stuff and
they he came up with this idea of maker
and that seemed like like wired it was a
really good name it was really short few
letters and it kind of took off so there
was the you know the Maker Faire and and
I didn't really kind of talk about that
lineage but I think it was to me was no
accident that the the Maker Faire and
the maker movement in the Maker magazine
that kind of all came out of San
Francisco I think there has been a long
trend trajectory of making your own
things as something that was sort of
honorable and I think there is a
connection between
the maker mindset in Silicon Valley this
this willingness to do something on your
own and that was again the whole earth
catalogue motif which was do it yourself
start your own thing do your own thing
and that has transitioned the maker and
I think it was at the beginning of make
magazine yeah I really like the term
maker because as a youtuber people also
call you a creator so I'm both the maker
and a crater which makes me sound like
I'm God also really humble humble God so
so I think and I I don't know about you
but I spend many hours a night watching
youtube videos about how to make things
I learned how to weld that way I learned
how to electroplate metals by watching
youtube clips and it's something I could
not have learned just reading a book and
I don't know do you find the same thing
are you learning how to do things on
YouTube yeah I mean you turn to YouTube
all the time it's yeah it's it's so
readily available and it's it's just
crazy and I feel like there's I mean of
course it's like the issue quality
control like how do you trust the people
making these videos but then you just
read the comments and they're if
somebody is an expert and they're doing
it wrong like the first comment is gonna
be somebody me like actually it's called
XYZ so are you finding that people watch
you to learn how to make things
no I'm that would be really scary
yeah but I'm utterly uneducated a choice
that I made when I started in my channel
cuz I was like I started building these
things as a way to learn and and a lot
of people do tutorials around especially
around robotics and electronics and I
was like I'm not in a position to teach
people like that's not I'm a hobbyist
like I'm a happy hobbyist who happen to
get a big audience
and I think there's a lot of people who
do such a great job of tutorial so I
guess I could get away with saying that
it might be inspiring yeah I mean that's
something maybe somebody watches it and
they're like yeah I also want to build
stuff or if she can do that I can do
better
it started as a compliment and then
ended as an insult I really like it it's
also I mean to me like engineering and
approaching engineering is really
daunting because there is a lot of like
it's it's a scary process it's something
that's really scary to teach yourself
and to take on and also in engineering
there there's a lot of like kind of
expert culture and for me setting out to
build shitty robots was a way to kind of
like deflate that and be like hey I'm
not setting out to be an expert and
people can criticize me for building
this project but I was just doing it for
fun
I just feel like people you kind of want
to avoid a culture where people are
scared of doing making mistakes yeah I
think that's one of the the benefits of
your videos is that you allow yourself
to make mistakes you you you sort of
celebrate and sense things that don't
work as a means to inspire other people
to you know make things that do work I
hope so yeah or maybe it's just this is
the start of the idiocracy this is how
it so one of the things that I'm really
interested in is sort of where this goes
into the future and how the maker
movement how doing it yourself might
continue to evolve and where it might go
in another 10 years or 20 years have you
ever thought about well if things
continue the way they do in this world
of makers and creators in ten years
it'll be like what do you have a vision
I think it's more that like we won't
want to the same I mean now in
in education there's so much about
learning a thing and what I hope to see
more is learning to learn because now
it's like things are evolving so fast
you can't really know everything or be
an expert in a field because things are
evolving really really fast so it's like
you just have to know how to find
information and how to figure it out and
how to solve problems so I hope that
that's like and that goes beyond the
maker movement that goes can be on
everything but just what it means to be
human these days yeah I would agree
wholeheartedly I think that the the
central curriculum of any kind of say
high school level graduation would would
be knowing how you knowing how to learn
and specifically knowing how I learned
best knowing how each person to graduate
with knowing how they learn the best in
all the different situations and that
super skill of learning how to learn and
optimize for yourself so that you knew
exactly how you learn best would be
really the thing that you want to
graduate with how do you learn best well
you know I think the thing about it is
is that it's actually I've been
searching and I have not found a single
curriculum that would teaches you how to
learn how to learn and none that teaches
you how to optimize your own learning
and so we don't know I mean I don't know
how I learn best I would really like to
know that but I think that is the meta
skill that is a super skill that you
would like people to graduate with and I
think would take a lot of work I think
would take a lot of teaching testing
trying things and training to be able to
do that so it's not something you could
absorb by itself I think it would be
something illiterate like a literacy
that you would have to be taught and you
graduate with and I think that would be
the thing that that schools should pride
themselves on teaching and really the
only thing you need to do when you
graduate so instead of having like what
are they calling Myer Briggs personality
categories you have learned our
categories exactly right and you're like
you're this type of learner people have
are all different types of learnings and
so you still have to learn how to learn
different situations but you would
understand how you learn
best in those different situations and
that would be the ultimate maker skill
what is the thing you learn recently in
welding I've been playing around with
electro nickel plating and then I'm
learning teaching myself how to edit
video and I graduated from iMovie to
Premiere Pro so and how about you what
have you learned recently whatever oh I
did not expect to get that question
bounce back at me you know whatever I
learned recently um I mean I'm learning
I'm starting a product development
country companies so I'm learning a lot
about manufacturing and there's a lot to
learn about it but I really I really
want to learn welding I have a welding
station I have a fume extractor I have a
welding hood I just need to learn yeah I
also have a fight fire extinguisher it's
to fire extinguish no I think I think
that's again that's the inspiration that
that for me the whole earth catalogue is
that you can learn new things you have
these possibilities and you know you go
through the pages and you're like oh
that you can do this you can you know
preserve skulls with with bleaching
whatever I think I didn't know you could
do that now you can and so right people
are gonna take us to heart or is it just
your own skull is it's like a new beauty
trend it was like yeah yeah really
bright skeleton yes yeah it's you have
to use hydrogen peroxide that's the
secret don't use bleach you chive and
peroxide everybody taking so
[Music]
I anyway do you have anything else you
what would your advice be for people who
are making things in 30 seconds yes
really cherish your enthusiasm we're
really good at teaching people how to be
Duty driven and be diligent about doing
things and I noticed that for myself a
much better fuel is if I'm genuinely
excited about something and that's when
I really get [ __ ] done but it requires a
lot of taking care of yourself and
making sure that you have the right
perimeter so just figure out figure that
out that's rubbish advice not quotable
at all that's Swedish that will work
already what about you I think the thing
is is beginning with failure I mean
count on the fact that you gonna fail
and that failure is to be accepted and
actually welcomed so the first things
you do second things even the third
things aren't going to work and that's
just perfectly okay and you should
really embrace that so
make stuff that fail yeah all right
thank you Kevin
thank you see mom Danica and next up I'd
like to ask Howard Rheingold to come up
to the stage I'd originally met Howard
and I originally met Howard in 1991 when
for a moment someone thought I could be
the publisher of whole earth of which I
knew I could never be so I've been very
grateful that Howard took that
leadership so 1968 was the year that not
only did the whole earth catalogue first
appear but it was the year I graduated
from college and headed out into the
world things are pretty [ __ ] up now
but 1968 was was kind of apocalyptic and
and I think that that like probably most
of the people in this room who are old
enough I I carried that first whole
earth catalogue from place to place with
me for quite a while
it was both an aspirational guidebook to
how I might design a life for myself but
also it was an inspiration and an
invitation to try to repair what was
going on in the world and a strong sense
that that you get from looking at the
video or looking at those old catalogs
that that there was a community of
people who were doing this I didn't
really join the enterprise for about 20
years when I got involved with the well
and started spending an inordinate
amount of time hanging out online with
what my wife called my imaginary friends
many of whom are out here and I didn't
really think about community until I was
challenged by by Kevin now Kevin tried
to get me to write for whole earth by
but I couldn't afford to do that I was
trying to make a living as a writer and
he only paid $250
so he would come to my house and provoke
arguments and he challenged me to
explain to him why I thought the well
was like a community and then he said
what you just said write that down I'll
pay you $250
so that then that made the same
Enterprise seem a lot easier that
article was published in 1987 it took
some years to get a contract write a
book about people communicating through
computer networks because editors kept
telling my agent and only electrical
engineers would would want to do that
and they wouldn't sell very many books
almost immediately after writing the
book I started getting a lot of flack
from critics and academics and scholars
and I didn't aspire to be a social
scientist or a scholar I was just trying
to write a book and make a living as a
writer but immediately the criticism
came that well these aren't really
communities and in fact you're degrading
the idea of community so I started
thinking about that but I didn't really
drill down on it until about 2005 when I
started teaching college students about
virtual community and what's now called
social media and looking into it I
discovered that a sociologist came up
with 95 different definitions of
community that you could find in the
social science literature so we can
define community but it's not a
definition that everybody is going to
accept and it's not an objective
definition that that exists in the world
outside of our are wrestling with what
community
and in many senses it's a projective
test about our hopes and and fears about
the way our lives and and the world
seems to be changing largely because of
the advent of communication technologies
and in fact sociology started when
Ferdinand tönnies in the nineteenth
century started writing about the way
life was changing when people moved from
villages to cities and from norms and
customs to contracts he called it oh my
mind's gone blank on it does anybody
remember what those words are
Oh so back then it was modernity that
was happening and now of course the
changes that come in our cities and our
social lives through communication
technologies are so much more global and
are happening so much faster and we're
discovering that there are all kinds of
great communities out there and there
are also Nazis and in cells and
terrorists and gamergaters community
seems to have this aura of being this
nice thing that used to exist but
doesn't anymore but it's something that
keeps changing and people who don't have
nice ideas can have communities too so
there's more to say about this but
fortunately we have some time to to talk
about it so I'm going to invite chip
Conley to come up and talk for a minute
[Applause]
I'm doing my best to keep up with
Howard's
wardrobe pretty impressive colors and I
just before I get started I say to
Stuart when I started my first company
Jawad Aviv hotels 32 years ago the first
thing I had in my business plan was
start cheap small and local which I
learned from you from Hollerith catalog
thank you so I'm gonna take us back
actually a lot longer I mean took us
back to 1910
eeehm Forster wrote a book Howards End
started the book with an epigraph only
connect but what you don't know is
probably is a year earlier he had
written a book or written a short story
called the machine stops machine stops
was all about how in essence it's
basically where we hearted hate to be
honest with you it's how the machine
actually became the intermediary in
terms of our connections so almost
exactly that same time Emile Durkheim
wrote a book and and coined a phrase
going to term collective effervescence
he studied religious pilgrimages and say
how communities came together and what
happened when communities came together
around a certain mission is that their
ego evaporated and a communal joy
emerged
well I've experienced that at Burning
Man for about 25 years
and I'm on the board and I as I spent
more time imagining collective
effervescence of a community I spent a
few years created a website called fest
300 that featured the 300 best festival
oh thank you
featured the 300 best festivals the
world my job was to be the most
interesting person in the world to go
around to all these festivals and
experience collective effervescence in
community now I was doing this at
exactly the time that URLs we're awash
in them and yet people needed this IRL
experience the in real life experience
I'd saw that as a boutique hotel you're
here in San Francisco where I connected
our guests who come
to our hotels with locals we call it the
Golden Gate greeter program where we
connected locals with people visiting
the city and then for the last five and
a half years I've been at Airbnb with
helping the young founders steer the
rocket ship and in charge of community
globally for Airbnb for the four of
those five and a half years and my role
was to actually help bring an online
community the especially our host
community together in person on occasion
and we did it exactly at Fort Mason our
first host community event in person and
night in 2014
1,500 hosts here 6,000 hosts in in Paris
a year later and then 20,000 hosts a
year later from 110 countries and the
thing that I noticed more than anything
was the idea that IRL and URL are not at
odds
you know the idea of connecting with
people online and then figuring out how
to meet in person so we are mirror
neurons could dance together which is
something that's hard to do online is
what we have and if you you know for the
future and so the last thing I'm going
to say before I bring Howard back out is
I want you to close your eyes for a
moment close your eyes I'm gonna do the
same and imagine when you hear the word
community what is meaningful to you
around that word what does it conjure up
for you what is it that community does
what community do you think of that
actually brings a smile to your face and
a spirit to your soul and as you think
about that community ask yourself is it
in real life or is it URL and with that
I'm going to ask you to open your eyes
and
Howard come on back on stage and we're
gonna we're gonna arm wrestle about
virtual versus in person hi hi go mine
shaft and gazelle shaft well you know
you've you've had that jacket since the
mid-80s if I'm not mistaken correct yeah
I wore it because it was in the film and
yeah exactly so it still looks good and
Cheers
so we got a community here in this room
and there in real life well I think I
would like to ask you is what do you
think about URL versus IRL is it a vs.
or is it an and is you know what do you
think well one one of the reasons I felt
that that the well was very community
like and it's something that I think all
of us still experience is that we were
able to connect with people that that we
either shared an interest with or
sparked some some some kind of
attraction that that we might not
otherwise have connected with and you
know many of those people remain
imaginary friends some of them are on
the other side of the world but there's
there is almost kind of gravity that
draws people together so I'd say that a
maybe more than half of the people that
I know now our people that I originally
met online
so and you know you mentioned Burning
Man when and I I guess 1994 in 1995 when
a lot of techie started going to Burning
Man I remember people remarking that it
wouldn't be possible without email and
that a lot of what brought that
community together just had to do with
the the infrastructure for connecting
people when I started thinking about
what what was unique about this new
computer mediated communication I
thought well you can connect with people
that that you want to connect with even
if you didn't know them
and it's a many-to-many medium but at
times looking at social media and how we
see these tribes who then are fighting
with another tribe and and frankly don't
have necessarily civil decorum in terms
of how they communicate how do we solve
for that I mean I funny other fact is
it's the 50th anniversary of mr. Rogers
neighborhood and like back then you know
yeah let's I saw that duck I flew from
Miami to San Francisco I had a speech in
Miami this morning strangely enough and
I flew today and I watched that film on
the way back and it's interesting to
look back to that era 50 years ago mr.
Rogers and the neighborhood the
community and there was almost like a
civil decorum that goes on why is it
that we've so fallen off that path in
the virtual or the digital world well I
don't think I don't think we're happily
I don't think people have become more
coarse and vulgar and mean I think it's
just more easily visible to us now and
you know this idea that communication
technologies are changing community not
for the better
is not a new idea of Robert Robert
Putnam wrote about Bowling Alone and the
decline of social capital and America
and what he correlated it with and he
tried correlating it with everything
else race relations women entering the
workforce and he would--he he ultimately
correlated it with was the the rise of
people watching television all the time
so well there are a couple of things
that that I think are important one of
them is the public sphere and I'd like
to talk about that and I think the other
thing we need to talk about is that
community is not this thing that used to
exist or that exists in an ideal form
it's something that we should wrestle
with and particularly since things are
changing more rapidly for what Tunney's
was involved with was a change that
suddenly changed the way people had
lived in their villages for thousands of
years
now we get that kind of epical changes
on a decade basis I mean I recently I
recently found out I have prostate
cancer less than four weeks ago and I
was able to connect with a community of
its intermediate stage so it's you know
it's something that's concerning in the
past I'm not sure if I didn't have an
online way to actually research it and
then listen to people who actually have
had it similar stage to where I am and
then actually go out and communicate
with them and I have all of that as an
experience in the last four weeks and
then frankly to have the IRL experience
as well as know oh here's a meet-up of
people who are talking about that to me
it's a it's a it's glorious that I have
two different paths to actually have
that kind of experience that helps me
feel like I'm not alone well you know in
in fact in 1986 one of the things that
that really coalesced the idea of
community around the well was when when
Phil Katz son came down with leukemia
and we created an online support group
overnight now there's Gillian's of
online support groups 1986 that was a
new thing so that was 1986 but nine
years ago I came down with cancer and I
needed people to drive me to treatments
every day and many many people from the
well including Phil cat who drove over
from Berkeley to pick me up and drive me
to a radiation treatment and then you
know you're kind of isolated and and
terrified and being able to connect with
people online was really important also
I started a tumblr about it a because I
didn't want to tell the same story to
every person who asked me how I was
doing and and be because that had been
my way of connecting with people and it
was a way to get out a lot of these
feelings that you know your oncologist
doesn't want to talk to you about so you
know that's the bright side of things
that people who need to connect with
someone because they're in trouble can
find a lifeline so I want to go back to
the decorum thing and the civility thing
do you think that that does that somehow
cleanse itself over time or are there
some elements of either rules or social
mores that actually start to define how
we create community or connect in a
civil way amongst communities online
well my personal opinion about it is
that network of people who communicate
online are not necessarily a community
and one of the things that signals the
formation of community is that they
begin to enforce norms so there's a lot
of bad stuff going on online now there
was a lot of bad stuff going online all
the time now there's just a lot more
people online and when I started writing
the book the thought that occurred to me
that I thought about a lot was what's
the most important thing about this
communication medium if as we believe a
lot of people are going to be using it
and that brought me to the idea of the
public sphere that political
philosophers had been talking about that
I didn't have not known about until I
asked and it's the idea that democracy
is not just about voting for your
leaders it's not having a population who
are free enough to communicate and
educated enough to have conversations
that form public opinion and that public
opinion would influence policy and
there's a lot of bugs in that
particularly these days
and I'd have to say that my the critical
uncertainty was will the public sphere
be improved by people communicating
online will democracy be improved will
individuals have more freedom and I have
to say that I don't feel very optimistic
or hopeful about that now but
the difference between an optimism and
and hopefulness is that hope is a choice
and so I think one of the things that
everybody in this this room can do is to
think about how might we improve the the
public sphere I don't know that you can
do it in a top-down way and I do think
that education has a great deal to do
with it and our schools or educational
institutions certainly aren't meeting
that challenge so when I asked people to
close their eyes did you close your eyes
no I didn't think so
so when you think a community do you do
you go straight to the digital side of
it or do you actually think of an IRL
community and in real life community as
well well you have to understand that I
spent most of my life as a writer and a
writer is in a room alone which I think
was why the it became so attractive to
me to be able to communicate with with
people online so I'm probably not the
the best person to talk to about that
but dealing with my students who live
immersed in this world they have many
more choices of the kinds of people that
they can associate with and the kinds of
communal discussions that they can
participate in then then I had or my
generation had so I think this is a
there's a huge amount of freedom but
again the uncertainty is who knows what
to do about it people stumble into
places would be nicer if they could be
more prepared any last thoughts
questions comments well the the last
discussion about learning I think has a
great deal to do with what some of the
positive potential of life online is I
started calling my my classes
co-learning community
and I started calling my students Kohler
nurs and that sounds kind of superficial
but it really had an effect on them and
one thing that the the the media that we
have now provides is educational
opportunities that we've never had
before you unless you were really a
dedicated autodidact you really had to
go to school to learn things for
thousands of years
but now I would say if you ask 14-year
old how would you learn to play the
ukulele or configure a web server they
would say well I go to youtube and
search on it don't read the comments but
there's a lot that you can comment I
learn that one if you learn how to not
pay attention to the ugly stuff there's
a lot that we can learn together and I
think the one thing that's sort of
lacking Kevin was talking about learning
about learning how do we learn to be
learners in community with all of these
tools with with search and Wikipedia and
YouTube and and all of the social media
for connecting with each other if we're
not the teacher what if a group of
students wants to learn together and I
think that we're going to see that
develop so I'll wrap up by just saying I
think I am my experience in moving from
being a localized boutique hotel your'e
with a bunch of hotels all in the region
to becoming a hospitable hospitality
called the Guru in the company around
hospitality and community and to have
that be in 192 countries taught me that
it is definitely not a versus it's a
it's an and it's not you know URL versus
IRL that the opportunity for the web and
for the connection with others and the
efficiency of how you can find the
people who can become your tribe
beautiful online and then what it
affords is the opportunity to create
that community in person when you can
again if the person who you really
relate to the most is in Iceland you
know you may not see them all that often
but I really have found on a personal
level with this Airbnb community the
idea that you can actually create a
sense of passion with people and then
give yourself that opportunity to find
the people locally that you can actually
have the face to face in a real life
experience with because both of them
frankly I think both of them speak to
our humanity the desire to actually
discover people and the desire to deepen
a connection with someone which from at
least from my perspective happens more
easily in person I I would just add one
thing at the end it's an advice for for
people online which is I think one thing
that would improve life online a great
deal is that if a UH norm developed that
it's okay to throw trolls out that um
the First Amendment says Congress shall
make no law not let's let this jerk slap
people around in my living room and and
the number of people who will leave
because they're offended by censorship
is a fraction of the number of people
who never you never hear from them
because they don't want to stick their
head up and have something thrown at it
on that happy note we're done Thank You
Howard
[Applause]
Thank You Howard Thank You Chet well
we've gone from do-it-yourself learning
and communities both virtual and in
reality it wouldn't be a whole earth
event without thinking about the
environment there's no one better to
bring up that discussion and Stephanie
Mills Stephanie when Stephanie graduated
from Mills College at a very young age
she became the leading spokeswoman for
the environment and in 1980 I went on to
work at coevolution as part of the staff
team we just get your life right here
Thank You Ryan gratitude to mother earth
gratitude to Stuart and Ryan and their
colleagues for realizing this event
gratitude to Stephanie Feldstein for her
partnership tonight the image was taken
this summer in a stand of old-growth
white pine saved in 1973 from the
chainsaws by a small group of thoughtful
committed citizens
the plants are bunchberry and Canada
Mayflower gratitude to all those beings
Stuart master of compressed utterance
asked for five minutes on the last and
next half centuries more than a tweet
less than a tome 50 years as an eyeblink
yet despite many good-faith efforts at
every level to prevent waste and ruin
the growth of industrial civilization
has ravaged the earth depleting soil
water and biodiversity contaminating the
oceans and the atmosphere in 1968 paul
and an air lick dropped the population
bomb there were about 3.5 billion of us
then
over seven billion now contraceptive
means improved while political
calculation cultural conservatism and
patriarchy hampered their widespread
adoption sixties temblors of
revolutionary change cracked a few
foundations in 1972 from the Club of
Rome we got a world systems model
forecasting industrial civilizations
inescapable limits to growth in 1974
Congress heard of M king Hubbert scurb
mapping the limits to oil production the
end times for a petroleum driven global
infrastructure big business as usual has
continued critical thresholds have been
crossed a late-breaking discussion of D
growth is underway but yet to reach a
wide audience a half century ago we
thought about living more responsibly
access to tools enlivened possibilities
of household homestead village and
neighborhood self-reliance there was
hope of stalling the apocalypse
juggernaut there still may be while it
coevolution quarterly best magazine that
ever lived I also worked on the next
hole Earth Catalog its extensive reviews
of essential means like hand tools and
simple machines how-to books for scores
of timeless crafts a spectrum of advice
on farming and gardening and astute
reporting on appropriate technologies
remain durable goods where I live quite
a few young hand makers digital natives
cherish the catalogue for its can-do
spirit and for arraying the physical and
conceptual tools they wield they're
flourishing while reducing their
dependence on brittle systems and long
lines of supply what's coming
possibilities I hope for probabilities
to
dread possible a renewed stirring of
love for the earth respect for and
reciprocity with all beings both love of
place and interest in nature stem from
our long time past although these days
they court struggle in grief
along with authentic connection they've
got survival value belli botanists and
bird nerds fraud counters and foragers
begin as kids they're the ones who grow
up to be the Rachel Carson's and EO
Wilson's the water protectors at
Standing Rock maybe you've got such a
one hope so in the chaos of our moment
perhaps a new understanding is imminent
a fundamental change of heart is needed
and there are harbingers from the eco
Pope to ecological restoration
esteverena milles of our kind are
supposed to be uniquely moral actors
now's the time to prove it if our
descendants are to inhabit a whole earth
after this collision with ecological
limits we had Brett best embrace virtues
like Taoism x' three treasures frugality
fairness and humility we can polish up
our capacities for neighborliness and
mutual aid we may be as gods but we'll
live best as plain members and citizens
of our biotic communities thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
Stephanie Feldstein who's the population
and sustainability director at the
Center for biodiversity she leads the
center's work to highlight and address
threats to endangered species and wild
places from runaway human population
growth and overconsumption she is the
author of the marvelous animal lovers
guide to changing the world Stephanie
[Applause]
thank you Stephanie and thank you all
this has been a really inspiring evening
so far and I want to talk a little bit
about technology and environmental
protection because I come from the back
to the future generation in just a few
decades we've made astonishing advances
in technology we can all sit here and
watch the simone's amazing robotics
videos on computers in our pockets that
we can charge with the power of the Sun
it's pretty incredible it's things we've
only dreamed of in science fiction and
it really feeds this sense that someday
maybe when we have hovercars the world
will be different and throughout my life
there's always been this deification of
technology this belief that technology
will save us all whether it's from our
own mortality or from the damage that
we've done to the planet but there is no
high tech silver bullet that can change
the realities of nature including that
we're a part of it and that it has its
limits technology has done amazing
things of course and I enjoy being part
of the age of information and all that
brings and there's a long list of
advances like solar energy and water
purification and so many more that are a
key part of mitigating the decades of
environmental exploitation behind us but
technology alone isn't going to be our
Savior it doesn't let us off the hook
and it's a tool and not even the most
important one we don't need to wait for
technology to save us nor can we afford
to do so in 1970 Norman Borlaug the man
who
technology transformed agriculture
dedicated his Nobel speech to the topic
of how the Green Revolution was never
really going to free humanity from
hunger until the people who work to
increase food production started talking
with those working to decrease
population growth because the real issue
isn't that we lack the tools to solve
the biggest problems that are driving
the wildlife extinction crisis polluting
the environment and putting our own
species at risk we have the tools
renewable energy technology has come so
far that we can meet our needs without
fossil fuels we know that diets that are
more reliant on plant-based foods and
animal-based foods can cut the
devastating impact of Agriculture on our
land climate and water and we know that
universal access to reproductive health
care education inequality can reverse
population growth of course there is
still room for progress in making these
solutions more effective efficient and
safer than they are today but we don't
suffer from a lack of tools we suffer
from a lack of language we don't have
the social discourse needed to increase
access to these tools to end
overconsumption to realize the limits of
our planet to realize the cultural shift
that's needed for gender equity for
agriculture that supports all life and
an energy transition that's not only
renewable but just and we also need to
overcome the barriers of communication
and privilege that are restricting the
access to those tools so in addition to
those working on hunger and population
I'd also invite to Borlaug's table those
who are fighting for justice and against
poverty and those working for a future
where all species including our own can
thrive on this planet because if there's
one thing we learned this past week from
that report that came out from the
Intergovernmental Panel and climate
change it's that we're all gonna need to
work together if we want to avoid
disaster but it's been nearly 50 years
since for like speech and even now many
of our movements are barely on speaking
terms so if we're going to make it to
the next 50 years we need the language
to understand each other across issues
to mobilize people to influence
policymakers and the business
we need to think outside the capitalism
box we need to think beyond partisan
politics we need to acknowledge and
accept the limits to growth and
prioritize the tools that already exist
we have tools including laws like that
to protect nature like the Endangered
Species Act laws that could exist to
save our remaining wild places and
create a healthier more just world and
of all the tools that were
underutilizing
in protecting the planet the most
egregious one is half of the world's
population women are still oppressed and
harassed and kept out of government and
boardrooms now I don't want to discount
the progress that's been made socially
or technologically if I wasn't full of
hope I wouldn't be able to do this work
every day we are starting to recognize
how interconnected these issues are but
instead of fully using the tools that
are already available to us in many ways
we're still waiting for that hovercar
era to begin so whether we're working on
the details of policy or developing new
tools or trying to crack the code of
better communicating how to use those
tools or the urgency and self ability of
the problems we face it doesn't start
with technology if we want to if we want
a world 50 years from now that's better
than it was 50 years ago we must embrace
the solutions that are in front of us
and have been for years starting with
equality dignity dignity and respect for
nature and for each other
[Applause]
it sounds like there's some friends of
the earth out there well I want to start
with talking about it we have this
lovely photo behind us and you talked
about this quite a bit I'd love to hear
your from you on how a sense of place
influences the future of the environment
and our resilience well I think it's
attachment it's a it's a primary
attachment to place with distinct
character like I I live in the former
North Woods it's a it's a forested
region this was taken up in the Upper
Peninsula of Michigan a little north
yeah yes yeah that's what you say that's
goddess country I I think you you know
you can't it's hard to fight for what
you don't know you know it's hard to
fight for what you're not connected with
what you don't have a sense of and so a
connection to a real geographical
location with its own character its own
spatial dimensions its own watersheds
its own plant life even if it's if it's
that tough weedy committed plant life
that grows up in the cracks between the
concrete I think that it we need I need
we need my cohort means that kind of
passion and and attachment and physical
connection and also to resist just the
homogenate homogenize ation of the
planet the the stripping out of
biodiversity which you and your
colleagues are working against so
cannily and just the reduction of
everything to a kind of a slag
of the anthropocene slag so sense of
place biodiversity diversity of places
and commitment to sort of envisioning
the life systems the biota the new forms
of community biotic community they're
gonna perforce emerge in this era thanks
critical I love that term Anthropocene
slag I mean it's terrible but it's such
an apt description for so much of the
destruction that we see yes yes yeah
it's a love of the earth and any love
exposes you to the risk of sorrow as as
well as joy and to behold what's going
on on the planet in terms of the
extinction crisis just you know it will
tear your heart out day after day after
day yet what's so remarkable is the long
term long halt commitment that people
have to protecting the wild to
protecting wild lands or to regenerating
I have been with bio regionalist friends
here in San Francisco for the last
several days and learned about projects
here of native plant nurseries out at
Hunter's Point you know with kids from
that part of the city bringing back
wildness to characteristic wildness
particular wildness to this area so it's
indomitable as nature itself and direct
connection with that indomitable 'ti
really infuses one with you know renewed
love of the earth I think that love
peace is so important in you know
in our our ability to keep on doing this
work it's it's interesting one thing
that we do at the Center for Biological
Diversity is so every year all the staff
gets together for a staff retreat where
everybody gets to you know see each
other in person because we're scattered
around the country you know learn about
work have all those important
cross-program conversations all of those
wonderful strategic things but also a
feature of it has become the segment
that we do we're different people from
staff get up and talk about what they
love and this is something that started
a few years ago and it's just become a
really meaningful part of our time
together because people can get up and
talk about anything it might be the
species they're working on or it might
be their children who they're doing this
work for and I think that really helps
us connect because sometimes we take for
granted that those of us doing this work
professionally day in and day out are
passionate about it but you know we only
dig deeper from that there really is
that that deep love for very specific
things that we're fighting for yes
what would you say your what what being
are you inspired to to your work by well
I think my book kind of gives it away
that I'm a lifelong animal lover and and
it's kind of been an interesting
progression for me because you know I
was that little kid who loved all
animals but I didn't grow out of it I
really grew into it and as I learned
more about different species I was like
I love all of them like don't make me
pick one and then as I learned that I
realized that well if I love animals I
have to love the places that they need
to live too I have to love wilderness I
have to want to protect wilderness and
one of the things that's been
interesting to me as I grew older is
that that also extended to to realizing
that you know we're a part of this world
too and that compassion toward humans
and an understanding where other people
are coming from as well as really
thinking through what are some of these
issues of equality and poverty and
social injustice --is that we're seeing
around the world
that's all tied into the fate of our
planet and the fate of other animals as
well and so it's really kind of expanded
you know my compassion and my dry
to do this work yes there's no reason to
assume a limit to compassion I'm struck
by the inclusiveness of more youthful
and contemporary activism that youyou
you are part of a synthesis now that's
linking all of those all of those
concerns this is a jump but I don't want
to neglect to talk about this in
addition to being the author of a
full-fledged book stephanie is the
author of some very interesting poetry
which appears on the Center for
Biological Diversity x' endangered
species condoms packages and I wonder if
if you'd be willing to talk a little bit
about that campaign which is so
brilliant because it brings brings
population and an endangered species
protection together yes and brings
together that poetry degree that my
parents were sure was going to be
useless they know wind up with things
like packages of condoms with artwork of
endangered species and sayings on it
like for the sake of the horned lizard
slow down love wizard clearly a very fun
project to work on but you know they're
also a really important project because
as many people have noticed over the
past few decades talking about human
population has fallen out of favor in
the environmental movement but obviously
it's still such a critical part it's an
underlying driver of all the worst
environmental problems that that we're
facing today but a lot of people for
many reasons don't want to talk about
population it feels personal there's an
ugly history to it there are a lot of
different reasons so we wanted to find
creative ways to reach out to people
when you hand somebody a condom with a
picture of a polar bear that says
wrapped with care save the polar bear
it's an entirely
different way to start the conversation
and a really effective one and that gets
back to you know what I was talking
about earlier with communication is that
we need to figure out what are the best
tools of communication today and that
changes as we've heard from our other
speakers throughout this evening that
that's not a static thing is over time
the types of messages that resonate with
people the ways that you reach people
change and the endangered species
condoms are just a great project to be
able to bring this conversation that's
become really taboo back to the
forefront and in a way that's really
accessible for people it's a wonderful
wonderful campaign one of my favorites
was cover your tweedle save the burying
beetle the classic thinking about
conversations and scale you know and and
resolving some of these terribly
contentious issues I I live in a
smallish community and I wind up going
to Township meetings and face to face
having disagreements about land-use and
just how we see living in a particular
place and so I wonder you know it's like
maybe the reason we Bank so heavily on
technology to save us is that
well-meaning attempts at social change
often go astray so you know how
important do you think are factors like
scale and locale in making the shifts to
equity justice and more sustainable
provision I think the other thing about
social justice is that it's hard and
it's a long process and that can get
really frustrating because these are
problems that we want solved yesterday
and the technology promises is a
shortcut but the thing that we need to
be aware
is that shortcut getting us where we
want to go you know when you look at
things like if you think about where we
started with Norman Birla its
technological advances and what that
promised for higher agricultural yields
that was at a time where you fast
forward to now and I don't think he was
envisioning a world with twice as many
people where we still have massive you
know numbers of people who are going
hungry every day and the middle of this
country has been turned over to GMO mono
crops so that didn't really get us where
we want it to go and and when you look
at agriculture it's a great example to
get to the point about scale and locale
is that you know if we were thinking
about agriculture in you know more of a
localized and diversified way we
wouldn't have this GE mono crop problem
if that's what we were going into
valuing it and I think the other thing
you know another metaphor for this is
you think about technology as being a
hammer it's great if you have a nail but
not everything is a nail and I think we
really need to respect the cultural and
ecological diversity of different places
and different communities and not strive
to create one solution that's going to
work everywhere but really to look at
how do we make change at the local level
and how do we create these models that
can be adapted as needed to different
communities yes real oka lies to where
you know I am very interested in the
transition movement transition towns
movement because a great many folks
anticipate a world where there's a lot
less traveling and transport and a lot
more local self-reliance local
production for local needs and also a
regaining of us of the ability to
discern between wants and needs and to
address meeting basic needs locally so
enhancing life in those locales includes
regenerating the surroundings
the natural surroundings absolutely and
I think that one of the other things
that we get from local communities is
more integrated solutions I know that
you live in a community with a lot of
makers and you know we've talked a
little bit that in villages around the
world they're finding solutions that are
trying to address healthcare as well as
local economic issues and environmental
sustainability all together and I'd love
to hear your thoughts and how that plays
into this bigger picture well it it
hurts to bio regionalism which for
decades has been saying we need to
regenerate local cultures and and to
reclaim some of the longtime human
endowment for health care natural
provision and tutorial relationships
with other beings so we sort of shorted
out there for a second are you hopeful
that that reclamation is happening yes
yeah I do I do I think that that if you
know common ground can be literally
common ground you know the the land
under our feet and the for in my case
the forests that that we love and
learning how to sort of use it and
inhabit it on a long-term basis I mean
another hot button issue hard to talk
about is carrying capacity and which is
something that needs to to be raised in
all our discussions of how we inhabit
life places yeah absolutely that's the
one thing with technologies we've tried
to cheat carrying capacity but in the
end is we're finding out every day now
it's not a thing that will succeed at
alas thank you all
thank you so 30 some years ago I
answered an ad that read I'm looking for
someone to work on computers travel and
meet interesting people and I'm happy to
say 30 years later I'm still meeting
interesting people Thank You Stuart
come on up
Thank You Danica that's I actually have
slides there's a kind of reframing I
hope going on today in relation to
holders and it's getting over the sense
that somehow this is the whole Ursa
stewart brand and I'm you know sort of
the founder and editor of the Whole
Earth Catalog blah blah blah and I will
say some things about what people come
to and talk about but everything since
the Whole Earth Catalog I've co-founded
and I noticed this I've looked back more
carefully at the original Whole Earth
Catalog it was co-founded especially
with dick Raymond he died a couple years
ago who ran what John Markoff calls a
non-profit incubator one of the earliest
Inca beers in Silicon Valley the sign
over his desk said fail young I did a
fair amount of that working with him and
then happened to have a success and I
realized he really really was a
co-founder of holdeth catalog and if you
look at me in context of the reality of
what it takes to put out in this case a
whole earth epilogue in 1974 and that's
just half the people that worked on it
there's some of the rest of the half and
many of these folks are in the other
room and I hope you meet them later and
even the earliest Whole Earth Catalog
that we did in a garage up on skyline
Boulevard was a lot of people and then
down in the holders truck store there
was a lot of people originally the Whole
Earth Catalog was a subscription
operation and if you notice the lady on
the left with the braids there you see
her again with the braids and foreground
here handsome lady with dark hair that's
Lois Brittain her name then was Lois
brand and effectively she was a
co-founder of the Whole Earth Catalog
there she is doing the books I was
talking to her she's here talking to her
earlier today and we were trying to
remember how long was it before we
decided to pair
yeah she said well it was about a year
before either miss got paid we got paid
four more hours and I did and she said I
said how do you know that we said I
wrote the checks and she is very much a
co-founder of that operation you go on
later with coevolution quarterly of
people like Stephanie mills were in the
thick of making a complex publication
with many editors domain editor staff
editors line editors and so on and in
this photograph in the lower left
there's a lady who was then named patty
Phelan later became Ryan Phelan at the
age of 44 when she got tired of having a
diminutive female name and went to her
middle name Ryan and on it goes
we saw a bit of the hackers conference
and this was a hundred or so amazing
young people who were reinventing the
world and and got away with it
likewise that the well I was trying to
look for now what's a really good
photograph of everybody on the well and
there you have Java code and cliff Acala
or leadership on the Left Gale Williams
should be there and the photograph on
the right is actually everybody on the
well that's the server's where we all
lived in our virtual reality with our
imaginary friends so how did it actually
work in the catalog what actually
happened there with people and I've had
occasion to look at this just in context
of what people have come to say and a
lot of it had to do with just the
quality of stuff that we found and so
still the best book on learning how to
draw is the natural way to draw by
nicolai t's still the best book on
learning how to apply is languishes
stick and rudder we were able to find
these things is tough keeping them in
print sometimes we help keep them in
print there was basic stuff on like from
Helens got hearing on how to grow a
sugar bush a bunch of maple trees and
then get the maple syrup out of them and
make that at the same time how do you
grow a wine and make good wine out of
what you grow and viticulture
early on this is before videos took over
everything there was still the
possibility of learning in detail how to
make really good television productions
or film productions and you could go dad
ask that and people started doing things
like that one of the best of all
publications that came out at that time
from the Boston women's collective Our
Bodies Ourselves was a revolutionary
publication up to that point having a
woman's body was basically treated as a
disease and by medicine and Oh with the
women many of them doctors realized was
actually having a woman's body is one a
miracle to an amazing instrument that
wants tuning and they worked out all the
details of doing that and it wound up
being one of the real founders of the
women's movement I think to take that
kind of control or the tool up on some
body so time goes behind catalogs go by
coalition goes by and by and by people
started coming up oh your skewer Brandon
you know I still have the first Whole
Earth Catalog
and I quickly learned that you know I
straight up Wow you do very few those
exist you know I only have one and and
then they were describing I realized
they were talking about their first
Whole Earth Catalog but why did they
keep that what asking what that's
interesting why do you keep it mobile
mobile but then they would go on and
saying well you know that catalog is
what got me the hell out of Indiana or
Arizona or North Dakota maybe and what
it was was a for them a window on a
world that their small community was not
giving them at the time or they would
say things you know it's really what got
me started with making guitars it's what
really got me started with music and and
that's been my profession ever since I
you know I just did the whole ETL I
really set my life in the direction it
went it
well you know they're thanking me I
Billy I should be thanking them because
there is this gratitude that goes on and
what is the gratitude actually about
this is what I've been asking myself I
think it's about people getting not just
permission to do stuff to try stuff to
take over their own life carrying on
yeah that's the hell out of Indiana or
to things it was a encouragement to do
that just because here's as was
mentioned earlier by Kevin all these
tools and you get a sense of my god
there's lots of different doors and I
can peek through a bunch of them and
someone might just kick open and go try
it and see if it actually connects with
the world or connects for me yeah that
one didn't work but that one does and
that one didn't it lead to these other
things and so when Steve Jobs said it
was the Google book 35 years before
Google it was sort of the internet
before then in the sense of that there's
this array of possibilities that open
out in front of you and that invite you
into them and so I regard this as a form
of of conferring agency agency is
freedom and independence it's a sense of
I can do stuff I can do basically
whatever really interests me and the
Whole Earth Catalog was focused on the
freedom of the individual what's the
opposite of agency the opposite of
agency is basically victimhood
and one of the things I remember writing
somewhere along the way in one of the
Whole Earth Catalog says now what's
worth doing unmake victims start with
yourself branch out from there the
agency is one of the most fundamental
things that we can take on in ourselves
and encourage and others mm-hmm and
that's one of the reasons I especially
wanted to have my version of YouTube to
come on shortly
because when people ask me now where is
the kind of thing that conferring the
skills and tools where do you get that
now you get it from YouTube and we heard
that in in Kevin and Simone session
Simone has proved that we are as gods
might as well get bad at it those
fireworks are going off out there and
celebration of this party no yeah I
think she made that up and there's a
whole other level of YouTube videos not
just how to weld but how did you amazing
things and for that I want to bring up
Sal Khan
thanks steward really really honored to
be here well you know I just want to
give a for those of y'all who aren't
familiar what we're up to it and and
it's really an honor to kind of connect
it and because it was inspired by all of
what we're celebrating today for for the
past 50 years but for those who don't
know about Khan Academy we're nonprofit
with a mission of providing a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and for the most part it exists
on on the Internet
but it has a whole life of volunteers
the hundreds of thousands of people
contributing to it volunteering their
time etc etc and to get a flavor for it
here's a montage of at least what some
of the videos look like but it's much
more than that it's practice it's
feedback it's its assessment and
whatever else it's sound and I could
narrate it I guess I'm told the humidity
makes it feel hotter why is this
excellent question LeBron and you can
just see the pleasure he had the right
to privacy as such is not spelled out in
the Constitution of course the word
Liberty is the things actually can
interbreed although for these two in
particular it seems like the mechanics
would get kind of difficult I can come
up with if this does not blow your mind
then you have no emotion but you all
would appreciate Oilers identity as I as
I mentioned it's much more there's you
know millions of learners of all ages I
was about to say kids but we have people
you know 80 90 years old who are coming
here to to learn things out of interest
or to help out their family across
subjects and grades this right over here
is is just a story of kind of that the
type of potential were were hoping to
unlock on the planet about six seven
years ago
the Taliban take over a town in
Afghanistan and they forbid all the
young girls from going to school
this young girl Sultana was one of them
she was 12 years old at the time it
doesn't go to school anymore threatened
with things like acid burnings and so
she was lucky enough to have a family
that had a computer so it she did
something like 10 hours of tours a day
but then every waking hour she would get
on the computer and try to learn
first she tried to teach herself English
and then once she learned English she
got a relative to get her any reading
material she could get in English and
she had a time magazine and she found
out about Khan Academy from that and
then from there she just went from a
second or third grade level where she
was at
got her algebra or physics or chemistry
biology and she decides that she wants
to be a physicist and then she just
keeps going she starts leveraging other
resources things like the MOOCs that are
out there and convinced and and wants to
come to the u.s. she smuggles herself
into Pakistan to take the SAT because
it's not administered in in Afghanistan
they're shockingly well and that's when
when I someone introduced hey we have to
help her get to the US I
I tried forwarding it around we're
luckily Nicholas Kristof from the New
York Times also found out about Sultana
and he wrote this op-ed and what's
incredible and just shows you the type
of potential that that's starting to get
unlocked in the world is that after this
Sultana got political asylum and is now
doing physics research with one of the
with a Nobel Prize winning physicist at
MIT
[Applause]
Meiko memes and so you can imagine that
the so you can imagine that you know
this could be happening all over the
planet and it is on some level these are
all pictures of the resources being used
everywhere and this was work done by
other ngos volunteers probably the most
exciting one really in the same vein is
sultana stories the one on the top right
this was about three years ago I got
this these these photographs and I got
this letter from the young woman on the
top right
her name is aya and then she said that
she really enjoyed the the resources and
I immediately assumed that she was
middle-class for her she actually sent a
video testimonial her English was quite
good she clearly had access to the
Internet but then when I read the email
more closely it turns out that there was
a group of engineers from Silicon Valley
who are using all of their vacation time
to go to Mongolia and set up computer
labs with internet and orphanages and
what you see there those are the orphan
girls in Mongolia using using Khan
Academy and Ziya was one of those
orphans and what makes this story neat
kind of like Sultana story is that Ziya
has not graduate from high school and is
now the number one contributor to Khan
Academy in the Mongolian language and so
just to give you a sense of what at
least the video part feels like in other
languages I'll show you this the
Bhutanese community
okay to Jakarta in mean not in enhanced
with ink she always habaneros are Paran
on out on out duration the moon to the
moon the sultry skies important
you know we just tired
so you just seen him Barney
make more noise I watched that one I get
lazy so this is kind of the start of
what we're trying to do and really just
with with all of the thousands of
stakeholders now Khan Academy is clearly
much much more than than just me really
in the same spirit of the Whole Earth
Catalog
empower every person on the planet and
and try to make education really a like
clean drinking water or basic shelter
and just a human right and so with that
I'd love to
[Applause]
the Whole Earth Catalog is so absolutely
everywhere I just love what we're you
know seeing tonight is that how much
that's the case I'd love to hear a
little bit about how this whole thing
started for you you've been finance in
New York and all that kind of thing and
how did start yeah and some folks might
might know the the back story but it my
original background was was in
technology but then I ended up working
as an analyst at a hedge fund okay and
then I just gotten married my family was
visiting me up in Boston where I was
working and it just came out a
conversation that my twelve-year-old
cousin who was visiting Nadia was was
having trouble in math because of that
she was being placed into a slower track
so I offered a tutor tutor her remotely
when she went back to New Orleans and so
I started working with her long story
short she kind of got learned finally
learned unit conversion which was
holding her back so how heavy a
mathematician were you at this point how
uh how heavy a mathematician oh I was
pretty in fact that's part it selfishly
part of the motivation was you know most
of us in our day jobs don't get to go
really deep into the academic stuff and
so it was almost I like to visit
revisiting all of all of that but I was
yeah I was I was a pretty big math nerd
in in high school and college and you're
teaching there's kid really really
fundamental what geometry guys doing
algebra well it started with Nadia and
this was yes pre-algebra unit very basic
stuff you know one thing led to another
and Nadia started to really accelerate
then I started to work with her younger
brothers and word gets around the family
that free tutoring is going on and
before I know it it's 10 to 15 cousins
family friends every day after work and
I would just you know my wife she or she
know I would just like come home it's
like I gotta go I got I got a calls to
do and and it was really a and the first
Khan Academy was I started with the
software I got my cousin's all need more
practice and I saw that they had gaps in
their knowledge and I was showing this
off at a dinner party in San Mateo and
the host of the party I've give him
credit is lefkara ramzan he said you
know this is all cool Sal but how are
you scaling up your lessons and I said
uh it's I'm not and he said well why
don't you record him is
and put them up on YouTube I immediately
thought that was a horrible idea I said
you know YouTube's for cats playing
piano it's not for serious serious
mathematics and you know what the cat's
do not learn from other cats playing
piano apparently they do apparently has
to start somewhere but yeah and and and
and those that first content I put out
there I would tell my cousin's like hey
this is there for you watch it ahead of
time that way we would get on the phone
we can dig deeper and they somewhat back
handedly told me after a couple of
months that they liked me better on
YouTube than in person and I took it as
positive feedback and I kept going and
you know soon people who aren't my
cousin's were watching and it in a very
similar story to what we heard earlier
kind of took on a life of its own and
around 2009 I couldn't focus on my day
job anymore and we set it up as a
non-profit and here we are so teaching
that's a little difference in teaching
welding I think it's it's not so much of
a show and then do a like there's a lot
of sequential stuff you have to get
before you get the next stuff and how
does that play out how do you make that
actually go forward I think yes and no I
think that's probably part of the
problem of how traditional education
handles math or frankly science is that
kind of teach it as a series of things
to know or it's a series of stuffin for
sure that it is that but it is there's a
certain art to it and there's a certain
and I think there was it was it was luck
frankly that the first content I was
making it from my family and so I was
very you know we've been talking about
being open to just showing mistakes so
there's there's a certain charm I guess
of some of the early and even now where
I would actually try to solve the things
in real time they weren't planned and so
you see me go down a path and say oh
wait that's not exactly right or I made
a little error and I get all sorts of
letters from people now some people who
are you know adults saying that was the
first time that I my anxiety went away
because I realized that it's okay to
make like because when you go to class
everyone that you know the teacher does
it like it's obvious that you just would
immediately do those steps where it's
not even someone who knows what you know
you kind of stumble around a little bit
make
mistake but then you fix it you laugh at
yourself so I think it you know I think
they're like welding or almost anything
there's a there's a art to it there's a
little bit of a hey you know when this
doesn't work try this type of thing
so one of the inversions that occurred
that it is I think quite profound is you
went to class to see lectures and and
then you went home and did homework and
all by yourself or maybe with a sibling
or something if you're lucky and what
you did is basically arranged so that
the kids go home and see your lectures
and then they come back to class and and
how does that work what do they do back
in class yeah this wasn't my idea this
is teacher started emailing me and
saying hey you know that was a really
good you know or a respectable thing
explanation of photosynthesis and now
the kids can get practice so I don't use
my valuable class time for that anymore
for just information dissemination I
could use that for more human
interactions and that's when a light
bulb kind of went on in my head is like
gee this could you could rethink
everything you don't have to have kids
all tracked and you know by similar age
or similar perceived ability you don't
have to have every kid work in lockstep
it started to dawn on many of us that
and you know the Benjamin bloom wrote
tons about mastery learning but was just
never practical for everyone to learn at
their own time and pace but now it was
now the tools are there not just Khan
Academy but the MOOC saw everything on
YouTube and so it was really learning
from the educators telling and this has
always been happening in humanity
seminars and humanities seminars the
teachers and read to you they ask you to
do the work ahead of time so you we can
be humans when we come to the classroom
but strangely in a lot of stem type
subjects it wasn't it wasn't the case so
you started out in stem but then he
moved in the direction I took I took the
earthing in the French Revolution I was
reading a novel about the French
Revolution see what these guys are doing
on that it was a neat little a power
thing that you did well yeah that's part
part of the selfish motivation for me is
I get as part of my job is I get to dig
deep into things that when
learn it the first time in school you're
under pressure you don't have to I'm
like I want to learn about the French
Revolution and now I can have a medium
to say oh that is cool and I can show
that and hopefully there's some you know
people like that because it's not coming
from someone who just you know has known
this stuff for thirty years at like the
back of their hand is someone who's
discovering and we kind of discover
discover things together you know one of
the things was sort of a surprise for me
in education so I prep school and
Stanford and undergraduate and all of
that and then I was gonna be I was
supposed to go on to graduate school in
biology because I did okay in biology
and then but I've been at ROTC so it was
gonna be active duty as a army officer
and I could have cut that short and
don't hit with some kind of doc and
postdoc and all that stuff but I really
didn't wanna and so I did two years in
the army active duty where I learned
about training and training blew my mind
it was this you know total equality of
outcomes situation where you will jump
out of an airplane five times at the end
of the ceremony of course whether you
like it or not whether you do the
homework or not that's what's going to
happen and insistence on outcome and
then just the forcing of it and I saw
the quality of teaching often by black
sergeants of just things like how to
Downton you know how to do a parachute
landing fall and things like that was
just outstanding it was it was they done
it a million times
and you could say well they're really
tired of it no they're really good at it
and and the the training just knocked me
out and it was the most important thing
many important things I think I learned
in the military is that that kind of
focus on just getting it right is an
amazing thing to impart is that part of
what is going on with your courses do
you think yeah you know the central
thesis is right now we're living in a
world if I asked any of us you know what
percentage of the population you think
is capable of contributing to cancer
research or starting the next Google or
you know writing the next novel most of
us will say well today it's 1% maybe
maybe with the great education system
it's 5% but I think that's because we
have some blinders on on what's possible
it's based on our experiences where we
would go through the system work working
in lockstep we're all accumulating these
little Swiss cheese gaps because we're
all being pushed along at the same rate
and at some point we see a lot of kids
hit a wall in algebra class not because
they're not bright
not because algebra is difficult it's
because they had some gaps in unit
conversion or how's my wall is the wall
and it's usually gaps in algebra and it
you don't even know it or physics and
it's gaps in calculus and we are seeing
more and more that if these kids can
fill in these gaps that's what's keeping
so it's really it's a you know I'm
starting to get more and more convinced
it's not just 5% or 10% who can do these
kind of be members of the creative class
so it's a week but I think it'll be 40
or 50 or 60 or maybe 100 percent and
it's almost an imperative that it does
get to that world because you know we
see what's happening with automation and
and the need for physical labor as much
in a lot of industries or even
information processing and you know I
couldn't imagine it we need to go to the
Star Trek reality where everyone is a
Explorer a researcher a scientist an
artist of some kind
how soon please yeah it's happening
faster than I would have predicted and
you know that kind of leads to a
question for you you know with the
Stewart what was the Stewart of 1968 be
thinking if of the world today what what
is beyond 1968 Stewart's expectations
and what is a disappointment for 1968
Stewart just played we don't have space
colonies yet Jeff Bezos is working on
that when it's I'm glad to see it
surprise and delight that the population
which had been a major issue at that
point so is so steep is leveling off and
leveling off pretty quickly thanks
mainly to basically Our Bodies Ourselves
thanks mainly to women really getting
control of the reproductive capabilities
and and also taking on things like
writing poetry Yongkang
packages how can you resist that I would
be grieved at finding out how many
populations of wild species are in
trouble they're not going extinct all
that rapidly at least not on continents
or in the ocean but they are on Islands
but just that the the especially the
megafauna keep going down and a special
personal project is to try to bring help
bring all the make up on the back so
that the whole world looks like it used
to look like which is it look like
Africa there's all these big creatures
going around and we've had some
successes so it looked like the
California mountain lion the Cougars
were going to be gone or bounty hunted
and they were headed out there totally
back now and they hardly killed people
at all unexpectedly not vengeful they're
just careful and maybe because they were
hunted for a long time so he's you know
there's a negotiation going on with
nature that we need a lot more stem
knowledge to really carry through I
think but that negotiation is taking
longer than I expected and taking on
climate with a level of seriousness that
it needs to be addressed is taken much
longer than I expected
put in 68 he remember I was you know 29
year old know squat and one of the
reasons I did the Whole Earth Catalog is
to maybe the way you sort of did some of
these courses to learn about them was to
you know I was saying I'm gonna help the
people doing communist figure out how to
do all these basics they care about they
didn't know how refrigerators work they
thought you could grow a garden by just
sticking a stick in the ground and
throwing seeds at it
and got over that and one season and
then either gave up or they actually
learned how to do it well I was one of
those people who wanted to learn all
that stuff and so the access to tools
and skills was my own desire to learn
those things but you know 29 year olds
have a
intense short view of the world and one
of the great things about this giving
more older people around and you'll
discover this as you get older is your
range of not only personal experience
expands but your sense of participation
in history expands forward and back and
the more back the more forward in the
way and then you start to get
comfortable in the long story and that's
sort of what I impart these days that
make sense absolutely and what what do
you think if I'll focus more on 1968
Stuart if 1968 Stuart were transported
today if you sit he or she were sitting
in the audience right now what do you
think they would be focused focusing
their energy onto for the whole earth
if I was any good I was still interested
in biology I'd be probably looking at
microbial ecology and Wilson gave that
answer initially the wonderful book
naturalist about his history is this is
one of the best sort of personal
biographies of a scientist and why is
that you see there is kind of a way to
feed the planet that way a way to
energies what is the microbial ecology
is most of life on Earth and in our own
bodies for that matter and it has been
it was a black box when I was a
biologist in the 50s the soil with the
black box and basically everything that
was very small was a black box they were
just starting to learn about DNA at that
point but now these things are becoming
transparent and you know metagenomics
with the ability to sample any body of
water and find out not only who's alive
in it but everybody who lives upstream
and things like this and then get a
sense of the genetic variability in them
any given species population I was
studying population biology but we were
doing it was you know less than one I
compared to you what you really need to
know
so the lore density is coming on and I
think we're still catching up with that
density which is an interesting
situation for us I think
and I see that we're getting right up to
nine o'clock do we have the last word or
two you'd like to know you know I I just
think the the the leg the tradition that
you started or part of I think it's only
going to accelerate and there's a lot of
things to be a little bit wary of in the
world today but I think net-net
there's just a lot of things that folks
that are in front of us you know
mentioned earlier YouTube is in front of
but how big of a deal is going to be and
I think we are over the next twenty or
thirty years not just education being
available but this idea of unlocking
this potential which is going to
accelerate everything hopefully in a
positive way what about yourself
you're here let's accelerate in a
positive way let's go all speakers back
up here take a big old bow
[Applause]
special thanks to playing feeling and
Danica Remy you created and organized
this thing and all the stuff that you're
going to see shortly thanks to the
speakers thanks to you the audience and
thanks to the many in the audience and
in the next room and who are not able to
be here who made 30 plus years of whole
earth this happen thank you to all of
them and thank you and I just want to
remind everyone that this evening was
really made possible by a lot of very
generous sponsors who helped make the
alumni come together to make this
program come together wired long now has
been an incredible support I'm Ken and
Matti Dyke wolde Juan and Mary Enrique's
Stewart and Ryan Gary Ostrom and Peter
and Kathleen Schwartz they really were
the ones who made it all possible for
this evening to happen so I'd like to
also say thank you to them
[Applause]
you
[Music]